salut une énigme par jour pendant 32
jours à l'intérieur du défi du mental
blog c'est une vraie poupée russe cette
chaîne tous les jours je vous donne une
énigme et je commence à chaque fois par
vous donner la réponse de l'énigme
d'hier si vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme
d'hier on sait la voir avant comment
mettre dix vaches dans neuf cases
sachant qu'on peut mettre qu'un seul
élément par case et bien il suffit
d'écrire une lettre dans chaque case
décrire réellement dix vaches ça marche
avec plein de choses hein ça marche
aussi avec 10 lapin par exemple hâte de
voir le nombre de pouces en l'air dans
la vidéo d'hier on voit la proportion de
personnes qui avaient trouvé est
aujourd'hui plus qu'une ligne c'est de
la survie
ces partis plus qu'un défi plus qu'une
énigme 7/15 vidéo sur cette série là va
peut-être vous sauver la vie un jour on
ne sait pas imaginez que vous êtes
enfermé dans un labyrinthe mais
n'importe quel navire est peut-être le
lavia le plus grand du monde peut-être
un labyrinthe fait en béton ou en
végétal comme dans alice au pays des
merveilles où le labyrinthe d'une
pyramide
ça peut être un tout petit comme ça peut
être un très très grand quelle technique
vous allez pouvoir utiliser pour sortir
à coup sûr du labyrinthe
quand je dis sortir c'est pas faire
demi-tour et juste pour reprendre la
sortie nord en trouvant une technique
qui va vous permettre d'être sûrs à 100%
de traverser ce labyrinthe une méthode
et une seule méthode qui existe j'ai été
voir sur internet
allez expliquer sur d'autres sites
n'allez pas l'avoir attendait jusqu'à
demain ça vous permettra de laisser
cogiter cette solution là moi je l'avais
trouvé tout seul donc c'est tout à fait
possible de la trouver
vous pouvez faire un pseudo labyrinthe
sur un papier pour voir si votre
technique elle marche ou pas et si vous
rendez compte qu'elle fonctionne vous
pouvez mettre des indices dans les
commentaires ou alors écrire simplement
moi c'est bon j'ai trouvé mais surtout
mettez un pouce en l'air pour qu'on voit
le nombre de personnes qui ont réussi à
sortir du labyrinthe
profitez bien du soleil abonnez-vous
avant de partir et rendez vous demain à
16h ciao